hey let's go Ambrose my name is P anyway
thanks for watching this video please do
leave a like if you enjoyed
I would really help out a lot help my
channel a lot when you leave it like
also don't forget to check out I'm doing
a giveaway so first link in the
description I'm doing an Amazon giveaway
it only lasts for 20 seconds so be sure
that you check it out right now make
sure that you also follow me on all my
other social medias Twitter Facebook
Instagram snapchat tumblr myspace
minecraft I'm also uploading videos on
dailymotion right now it's basically
just videos of me crying shut out to all
my other YouTube channels you to.com
such peopie youtube.com slash beauty and
of course users are calm / jacksepticeye
- I'm also starting an adoption program
where you can adopt my baby if you like
this video 5 times with your left thumb
as you can tell I have my baby right
here and you could win this baby
remember just 5 times let them like all
my videos
also if you tell your mom's best
friend's dog about my channel you get a
chance to fly in here from wherever in
the world you have to pay for it
yourself though and you get to stay with
me outside the office and don't [ __ ]
go near me and also if this video gets
at least 50,000 shares and likes I will
upload a video again tomorrow also you
can join my discord server for a grand
total of two thousand and eight hundred
dollars you can become a mod on my
discord server we like to talk about
what we thought about PewDiePie and how
he's running out of ideas
I prefer PewDiePie 2016
that's the kind of stuff we get into
it's a good offer
too bad it just expired I'm sorry
queue slow [ __ ] better luck next time
man but don't you worry
you like fidget spinners I'm getting a
no but that's okay I have a fidget
spinner you can buy it right now it's
not a joke you can buy it I recommend
buying at least 600 of them
you never know when they run out and you
always need more food just finish think
about it the end of the world is coming
what do you need frigate spinners I
really really mean a lot to me if you
guys check out all my fitted spinners if
you buy it well now you get one also
guys if you haven't checked out already
I'm starting a book club it's gonna be
here in Brighton we're gonna talk about
some of our favorite literature
I really recommend everyone poops it's a
fine piece of art that we're gonna
discuss we meet underneath the Brighton
Pier every Wednesday at 3 a.m.
also don't of course forget to subscribe
have you subscribed to this channel yet
but really it really mean a lot to me if
you guys do that also check out the Bell
button hit that Bell button I don't know
what the [ __ ] he does better please hit
the bell button hit hit the Bell button
hit the [ __ ] Bell button why don't
you [ __ ] understand Jay says follow
me on Google+ I don't touch that [ __ ] I
don't think anyone does but please just
do that that would be great for a chance
to win a fidget spinner and this one is
special because no reason no reason
download all my apps
I got chipper simulator legend of the
brofist purity bought download them all
and if you download them all and leave a
review saying Hillary Clinton you get a
chance to win Hillary Clinton that's
right I got hookups she's going to meet
up with you
Hillary Clinton everyone and also in the
next election if you vote Hillary
Clinton you get Hillary Clinton as a
president everyone it's a limited offer
2020 think about it we're not stopping
there leave a like on my comment on
jacksepticeye's video for no reason no
reason at all have you guys seen my
pornhub account
I got pornhub I got you porn I got
redtube
I got YouTube Bret no I don't forget to
check out my Spotify playlist
it's [ __ ] late as [ __ ] dog I got all
the tracks have I told you I've got a
mixtape let's listen to that [ __ ]
welcome to my mine we are mining
diamonds we are mine
[ __ ] yeah do you breathe on a regular
basis well if you like this comment you
could die a premature death we could
happen at any moment
are you dead yet I don't know if you
watch all my videos you will cure my
depression post this video on every
subreddit ever for a chance to become a
seagull
do you like seagulls will you are one
now tell your favorite teacher about all
my videos and you get a chance to get
molested also guys I'm going on tour
with Todd Lomond you it's gonna be so
[ __ ] good and you thought it was over
have you seen my roblox thread and it's
[ __ ] awesome we're discussing all
kinds of crazy [ __ ] my god you haven't
lived have you seen my Instagram main
page that is the [ __ ] best Instagram
eat bait in my minecraft server ah you
know I think that was it also check out
my other videos earlier I'll leave them
here and yeah just just check them out
check out I feel like my nipples are a
little bit too explicit but yeah dude do
check out do check out these this video
what are you looking at come on
check out
check out the other video I got tell
them go check out the video what are you
doing here go check out the other video
after you've done all the thing I asked
you though I leave a I left it all in
the description just what go on what do
you want
this is extremely boring this is like
just check let's check the video please
I know you're waiting for me to say
something funny it's not gonna happen
it's oh the video is done just just go
you're done are you not listening what
the [ __ ] is wrong with I'm literally
holding Edgar just to cover up my nips
realize it's pretty hot in here they
look a bit bigger than they shouldn't
don't you think I feel like I have good
nips they look a bit weird they look a
bit freakish like jacksepticeye's nips
you know no offense to Jackson to K of
course but I've seen his nips and
they're not attractive what do you think
Edgar he agrees 100% I got bored so I'm
just gonna loop myself so it seems like
seems like I'm here but I'm not has it
been has it been 10 minutes yet how long
oh there's no way okay I'm just going to
loop myself
you
all right guys thank you what Thanks